yo what up everybody it's your boy to
see here and make sure you check me out
on a bootleg cab podcast know what it is
blue light cats show special guest he's
got the number five record in the
country right now and climbing soon to
be number one yes sir my guy tusi is
here welcome Kevin's word man hey man
congratulations I appreciate the record
is on fire bro we pushing we pushing man
you've had like big records like love
Cycles like that but this is like a no
that's a big record it's a hit it's a
hit hit yeah that's it yeah like you've
had like you got plaques but this is
yeah yeah that's it that's it yeah how's
it feel to finally like get one of them
then you know what I mean it's a
blessing man just to see um just to see
all the love we're getting from it and
it's like that it's special when you
like originally recorded it did you kind
of have a feeling like this was gonna be
the one that kind of changed things or
you know you put so many records out
yeah off the rip uh I already know like
soon as I as soon as we I recorded it I
knew yeah yeah how do you pick Khalid
for the remix uh we just want to do
something different because you got the
future remix you got the Khalid remix
then we we gonna [__] around and go get
Morgan Wallen or something you get
Morgan have you talked to Morgan Wallen
I had somebody reach out to someone for
me I feel like he'd do it I don't know I
feel like he really wants to be down
ever since he got caught saying the
n-word I feel like anybody who asked him
he got to say give oh he's being the
most craziest spots bro every time yo
every time I I just be like I wonder
where he goes bro you gotta ask him to
get on the remix and if he says no you
could just call him racist no I'm not
doing that man
no man he's hanging out with a little
Dirk they're going fishing and [__] like
yeah yeah yeah I own a lot though they
they say he ain't mean it like that I
never see it I guess it was he was
saying it with the a like like he was
down to his boys like it wasn't a hard R
situation I think the harder situation
there's probably no coming back yeah I
mean it's different it's a different day
and age you can't be saying that no more
did you ever get any scholarship offers
when you were coming up yeah I had a
scholarship
yeah but yeah I had a scholarship for
her I had a scholarship to South
Carolina University for what though
football to play football yeah what
position uh I I used to play uh slot
slot receiver so you're like uh Wes
Welker yeah yeah
you can't be like I feel like if you're
a short wide receiver that's kind of
what you got to do yeah but I want a lot
of I was like yeah you gotta be slopped
but I was um
I ain't like weight training so like it
ain't work for me you just didn't like
to actually lift weights wasn't your
thing yeah no I'm not alone that ain't
really my thing so how long how long
were you actually
you know participating in college I
didn't go to college no you didn't go I
don't know so you were like [__] that
they didn't offer you enough money they
didn't offer you enough money yeah I
would have got like five I'd probably
ten you know big booty got five million
dollars to play the drums he told me
about it right here I thought he said
15. 15 million you never know yeah
listen if you if you out here playing
the drums like that
you should you should start a band now
or for sure like Tommy Lee got paid that
much money to play the drums you know
I'm gonna tell Boogie though yeah let
him know Boogie cap
oh yo ass girl
I got to see this I tried to tell him
without telling them I'm gonna tell him
Boogie oh he's great and we had a
hilarious talk he's a great dude yeah
yeah yeah I [__] with everybody though
of course I got to see that though yeah
five million boy your ass is dumb you
start rapping yeah like Drumline had to
have been about you bro yeah that had to
be about him Nick Cannon won't even get
in five minutes five million for
Drumline hell no what the [__] you're
getting five million boy big Boogie we
might need to go back to that show I
will manage you personally me too I'll
be a [__] manager your old man
you don't gotta run up and down all
these clubs and get them back ends bro
just play the drums play the drums [__]
this [__]
um I ain't had no scholarship like that
though uh talk about this album very
personal album obviously you're you're
naming it after you know your your
government yeah is this your most
personal because you're a very
vulnerable guy on record yeah man yeah
yeah I would say this is my most
personal album
um yeah most personal album tour just
got announced yeah yeah I mean 90 sold
out Jesus yeah that's so crazy yeah is
it yeah I'm proud of you bro cause you
[__] listen I'm happy you're on fire
bruh Hey listen when we did the club
event in Phoenix yep I [__] with that
[__] yeah he was uh we gotta run it back
on you'll be out there July 31st go get
tickets if it's not sold out already
it's sold out oh it's too sold out but
but but
let's run it back we gotta run it back
man I love Phoenix bro I need a house
out there you should get a house out
there a lot of people are doing that on
the low they all love that [__] yeah
that's that's my favorite place to go
lots of rappers live in Arizona but they
don't want people to know because they
don't want to like they don't want it to
be blown up like yeah they only they
wanted to be some location yeah yeah I
[__] Phoenix 11 11 baby the 31st
we're gonna figure it out it's a Monday
it's a weird night to do but we're gonna
win but come on no we're gonna we're
gonna pack that [__] out
um no but talk about this album uh I may
or may not have heard uh The Savage of
the 21 is on this thing yes the Savage
of the 21. yes the Savage of the 21. Mr
21 is on the album who else is on the
album future and Khalid of course yeah
yeah a lot of we're gonna take those
versions off when the deluxe come out
those versions coming off
wait you're taking the remix versions
off you know yeah yeah you know this
this is the bootleg cab show yeah where
we keep it real right well I mean listen
you got to kind of you got to put all
the versions on the album you gotta no
no no you don't you I mean you don't
have to but the label wants you to they
tricked me because they want that first
week that's what I'm gonna tell you
though to the artist that's out there
because ain't nobody telling me this
[__] y'all do not have to put all
versions if it's the it's all under the
same uh code IRS what's the name of the
code
code It's all under the same coding so
you don't have to put the remixes on
[__] no and they told me I had to and
that's why three of the same song is on
the album bro I never wanted to do that
[__] well you know I think the label
likes to
the you know listen French Montana once
put luck lockjaw on an album for like
five years you know it's like you gotta
make it look good you know yeah no yeah
don't don't but don't artists to artists
that's out there
people think it looked good and don't do
that [__] just put take the two songs
off and put another version and there
you go it's all in the same code and
ain't nobody tell me that [__] though
what are you uh what are you listening
to lately man like what is kind of in
your I mean you brought up Morgan while
you listen to Country I listen to
everything you listen to some country
like music suck nowadays it does me and
Neil were just talking about it bro I go
to all my other interviews you know I've
been waiting to get here bro all right
well you were late so yeah I go to all
my I was waiting for you
I go to all my other interviews and I'm
like yeah which I do love these artists
the artists that I name I [__] with
these artists but I don't really like
nowadays I don't really like music these
days
I saw it's all like um
saw the same stuff I think what's going
on is I like some of the songs though no
some for sure but I think this is what's
dope about favorite song is it's a
record and I feel like most artists
nowadays they're not they're they're
very they're just throwing together
joints sometimes there's like a half a
hook this is like a [__] wreck music
is not how it used to be right music
used to be like you know hits after hits
after hits like real hits like some [__]
you wake up to and it's playing on the
TV in the morning uh MTV and
[__] [__] that you like like it
was real hits right like
this [__] like [__] it's the cousin
rapping it's the streaming [__] it's
like hey man I got plaques off of this
streaming yeah bro like everybody trying
to do it and which is cool but like
that's why I thought it was dope to like
I feel like Dirk
my homeboy start just started rapping
this [__] I love him to death he got he
gotta leave that [__] alone
yeah that [__] ain't nothing did you
tell him that yeah no he's telling me I
love him though he's gonna watch this
well yeah he gonna see this [__] he
gonna see this [__] this is my homeboy
too is this hard is it hard to because
it is very I'm sure I've been told his
ass don't do that [__] though did you
tell him he's not good though
yes listen we used to Freestyle and I
used to tell him like bro
don't do this [__] this [__] ain't for
you but he ain't never used to try out
of nowhere he started trying it's like
he was playing around and now he's like
hey you made it bro I was in the cipher
with you bro I could do it too you know
that [__] ain't none he having fun with
it though that's what I love about it
but this [__] ain't like don't don't
waste your time trying to do this [__]
and you could be doing others I've had a
lot of close friends I have a cousin
who's been he's older than me he's been
rapping for 20 years and I've told him a
million times this is because I don't
know what you're doing bro at this point
you just buying studio time yeah I know
I know a few people like that though
it's like at what point in time do you
pull the Band-Aid off and go get a job
nah never you know they're gonna keep
this [__] rolling though
man you should be the guy to be like
honest oh yeah I got to be honest yeah
you are you sometimes your honesty it
gets you in trouble at times yeah
sometimes yeah yeah yeah what's up y'all
we gotta stop the interview real quick
to tell you about our good friends at my
bookie that's right it is NBA Finals you
gotta Hammer the Nuggets I don't know
they might sweep the the heat I would
look at the like serious odds on that go
to my bookie right now let's get some
money man all right baseball of course
is in full effect we got Stanley Cup
finals NFL seasons on the way sign up at
mybookie.ag right now use the promo code
bootleg and you will get that first
deposit bonus
all right look I don't care where you're
at you can go to mybookie.ag Let's
gamble on some sports they got the
casino you can do live Blackjack you can
do live roulette craps you could do all
kinds of slots and of course bet on the
NBA Finals bet on the NHL uh Stanley Cup
finals crazy shots of the Vegas golden
knights that's what I'm rooting for and
of course baseball season man all right
so look right now mybookie.ag use that
promo code bootleg uh and sign up when
you do use uh that promo code they're
going to give you a first deposit bonus
straight to your account free money all
right mybookie.ag go do that also got to
give a shout out to our family at Blue
chew that's right ladies and gentlemen
it's getting hot outside that means
I don't know what that means it's just
hot so I feel like when it's hot people
want to [__] more right so you know
fellas if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it happens to the best of us
I'm sure maybe you are old maybe you are
dealing with stress at work maybe you
don't want to sleep with the same lady
that you're married to over and over
need a little extra motivation to get
that thing stayed up you know what I
mean go to bluetooth.com use the promo
code bootleg and they'll send it
straight to your door three-month supply
of Bluetooth for free all right now
there's Bluetooth work yes it does
you're gonna get a free month supply to
be able to see for yourself
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg uh now
if you don't know what it is it is the
same active ingredient as Viagra and
Cialis but in a chewable form and you do
not have to go to a doctor's appointment
all right you do everything online you
don't have to go sit at a doctor's
office and talk to some old man in a lab
coat about your dick issues not
necessary anymore in 2023 all right so
go to Bluetooth sign up with that promo
code bootleg get a month supply for free
let's get back to the interviews are you
still uh are you still in a relationship
are you single what's going on yeah yeah
I'm still in a relationship
you kind of kicked back from like
posting your girl too much because
before I feel like you were out there
with it yeah is there a reason like why
like
um
it's just too personal yeah I don't want
people in my business yeah let him let
him listen to the [__] album if they
want to know your business yeah I mean
y'all listen to not sure if you want if
you want to hear about nazarea listen to
Nigeria it's a pretty wild first name I
love it yeah I don't know where the [__]
my mom got that from what I was about to
say is that a one-of-one type in first
name yeah you don't even want to know my
siblings name so please tell me not sure
and menajah
was she a Nicki Minaj fan nah hell no
yes she is actually yeah yeah she is but
I thought you meant like Nicki Minaj fan
like this is that where she got it from
nah menajah manager okay nominage
yeah like Tracy so Tracy sounds like a
90s Bay Area rapper or something like
Dre hyphen C you know from Oakland or
something yeah Tracy sounds like he'd
have a song with like spice one or
something all right you ready for the
other one okay a shot of you ashadia
yeah yo [__] lit yeah bro I don't
know where the [__] these names like I
have a shot of your best tequila yeah
can I have a shot of your best tequila
feel me yeah it's like that you know see
Yo shout out to your mom she's [__]
lit she was drunk next time I have a kid
I'm gonna call you I'm gonna say I need
I need your mom to make my mom to name
my kid yo it'll be some wild [__] yeah
nah yeah you don't want that though bro
I don't know what my mom was thinking
you know people be trying to be
different though shout out to her I love
her mom if you see this interview I love
is your mama very proud of you yes my
mom is very proud of me have you ever
had your mom call you about some Like
lyrics and like what the [__] is this
yeah hell yeah yeah hell yeah on the
album I said something about a dude she
was dating oh what'd you say
um the new album it's coming out yeah I
thought I was talking about this guy
named Terence who uh
man he was trying to he was trying to
get with my mom and I I guess it kind of
didn't work and he put us out we was
homeless he kicked y'all out kicked us
out with his homeless here and she
[__] my mom
and it didn't and when you were a kid
yeah Terence I mean but they grown
though ain't no telling what happened
she probably I don't know you want to
hear it yeah but still to kill me kids
out you know like you gotta go the kids
could stay he kicked us off you gotta
get the [__] out of here he kicked us
out damn so what I wonder what Terence
is doing nowadays yeah I wonder what
Terence is doing so what did Mom be like
yeah what the [__] I don't know how my
mama feel about me talk about this hey
Mom
uh were you talking about it on the
[__] house my phone that let me call
my mom
let me let me let me call my mom real
quick bring my phone got it we gotta
call Mom Dukes again call Mom and let's
figure out what happened with Taylor
let's figure out unplug it what was
gonna be the name of the next kid had
she had one all right
let's call Mom your mom's gonna answer
right yeah of course my mom loves me
that's a serious case on your phone I
respect it Bottega that's just the type
of case I mean yeah man I'm chilling Ma
on you see she loved me I told you hey
Mom what happened we're in the middle of
an interview with your son
is Kevin
um
you have a special talent of naming your
children amazing names
yes you did well you should
okay yeah okay you should write a baby
name book uh too what happened with you
and Terence
all right listen listen you don't gotta
you don't you listen hold on you don't
gotta tell him what but listen am I okay
to talk about this on the interview
okay nothing bad happened all right
oh yes he was a blessing he's gonna see
this interview and get so much Play
Chance was a great guy
[Music]
being an amazing friend who did
something all right God
blessed hey
I ain't gonna say nothing
you good
I'm trying to figure out what you want
hey hey hey uh I'm gonna call you later
and I'll tell you
I love you bye Mom love you love you I
love you nothing uh
um
hey not listen uh when I was a little
bit younger Mike couldn't do that but
she got to go now cause uh she's like
Terence is a great guy and he's a great
friend and he is a blessing Hey Boy
[__] know what you did I'm a home [__]
know what he did but
I need to hurt near here how's the dad
life treating you now I mean how would
your kid now like two life is great yeah
no [__] no it wasn't it I feel like he
had like a baby the last time I saw you
yeah he 11 boys oh [__] I did see you
like about a year ago yeah he was still
in the womb okay okay yeah he is still
in the morning she'll interview a lot of
people well I've interviewed you three
times since the pandemic yeah yeah so
well you don't get tired of me no you're
fine I feel like I should be like one of
those because I'll be seeing a lot of
dudes going to podcasts and be doing the
interview was like hella like they'd be
doing like them they what the [__] do
that [__] be I don't know I don't even
know what you just said like listen when
you know you know those guys like like
like
um that go on podcasts and do like a but
like you know how Boosie going on
[__] Vlad 24 7. so so boozy I feel
like it was on Vlad every two weeks what
the [__] is that I think because Vlad is
uh it's a business relationship they
have hey well come on let's if we could
do this [__] bro so so Vlad and boozy at
this point I feel like vlad's like our
Oprah now yeah like anything going on in
the world just wait a couple of weeks a
Vlad interview will drop and boozy will
tell you okay yeah yeah yeah that's what
I'm saying we can get this [__] rolling
yeah I know I'm not confrontational so
that wouldn't work with me right yeah I
hate confrontation confrontation's not
good yeah Mom and I feel like like you
got to be like
you got it you got to be cool with that
[__] well I think like
yeah I mean they want you to talk about
everything everything yeah I don't got
that [__] at me I I respect it yeah um I
was gonna say with your kid though like
okay 11 months old yeah so that means
he's like borderline walking
um yeah he's getting around climbing on
[__] like like if you like put him on at
the he can pull himself up on the cover
so he's he's mobile yeah yeah he's
getting around on the ground and [__]
yeah hell yeah yeah he's getting down is
it a lot because obviously tour is
coming is gonna be pretty hard for you
to take a a significant break or is he
coming on the road with you
um oh damn I hung up my phone call that
back uh but yeah he he gonna come on the
road he's gonna come on the road yeah
just a little bit yeah not too much you
got some wild fans man yeah yeah yeah
but the good thing is they are females
that is a good thing yeah that would be
kind of a wonderful thing to have like
I just dealt with um like the toxic side
of Little Dirk's fan base yeah and it's
like a lot of oh you [__] what you do
all I did was say this was like you
always wait who is wait wait wait okay
so you know how we started this
interview and listen yes we started this
interview and we said you finally got a
real hit
oh wait wait oh me you said you finally
got a really you know what I seen what
you said all I said was I seen what you
said he has yet to get a real thing what
you said and mind you now [__] oh so
listen now he has one yeah right yeah
but his fans are [__] weirdos what do
they say they're like little white dudes
like with OTF tattoos who swear they're
from like oh block but they're from like
[__] Scranton Pennsylvania or some
[__] and they're just in my [__] DMs
like going crazy right so it's like at
least you don't have those like at least
it's just females you know yeah I damn
yeah I seen what you said though but I
wasn't wrong it'd be like if I told you
a year ago yo you got plaques but you
ain't caught a hit hit yet I'll be like
yeah that's true right but now you got
one now you got it you got a [__] hit
bro yeah finally I mean after like after
15 years of making music I have no I'm
rich who are we calling on the phone on
the interview now
yeah mute it though but yeah though man
now I gotta make sure my girl straight
because she at work and she about to
leave work
you know
I don't know you know you're [__]
Rich right yeah yeah I mean yeah you'll
be like staying home here yeah and I
almost deaf all right it's coming is
that coming soon sure you guys get
married she don't want to stop though I
respect that that's a problem that's a
good thing because she wants to have her
own [__] yeah you know most women yeah
would be like hey I'm chilling yeah you
know nah she was she she
um
she's just she she don't she won't work
does your lady deal with uh the fan
fandom pretty well she probably knew
what she signed up for it's not like
this is new yeah yeah
you see each other have you ever had a
stalker
no not really like nobody pulled to the
hotel room follow you on like like
[__] City yeah yeah I had that I had
that yeah I had a lot of that uh
yeah I'd have had that but it won't it I
don't really pay no mind to it though
right it's never like stalker like bad
stalker like following me everywhere
knowing I'm gonna be like every second
like
because we won't play that [__] right
they won't play this got to stop the
interview to tell you about our family
at Odd Socks that's right the most
comfortable socks in the world ladies
and gentlemen uh go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg calf or bootleg both promo codes
work you'll save 20 out at checkout uh
20 off these are the Odd Socks Basics
all right now you can get like a pack of
all black pack of all whites of course
they got all kind of crazy licenses WWE
Cheech and Chong they got Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles they got SpongeBob
SquarePants bruh look they got the
SpongeBob SquarePants Krabby Patty
draws
yeah now you don't want crabs but you do
want Mr crab's underwear because these
are fire all right so look go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code uh bootleg save 20 off a
checkout and uh yeah listen trust me
when I say most comfortable socks you'll
ever put on your [__] feet
and the most comfortable boxer briefs
what are we talking about man all right
autotoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off of checkout great gift and
and just treat yourself all right also
got a shout out to our family a King
Palm now if you guys don't know about
King pong kingpong is all natural baby
yes all right we're talking about the
leader when it comes to uh tobacco-free
natural organic Leaf wraps if you're a
smoker a totor a straight west coaster
you know what I'm saying whatever you're
into King Palms they got it for you
what's great about um these these are
like one of the best uh products that
they sell now this is a terpene infused
tobacco-free leaf
and what's dope is you stuff your flour
into it
and then you press on the thingy you
know what I'm saying
and then you got flavor I'm going to
show you what it looks like when it's
stuffed
with some great tree from Jardin of
course
ah look at that
right get that thing stuffed up
the tip has got that flavor in it uh
wherever you're at man make sure you
check out the uh
um you know they got the smoke shops
they got those on lock they got
7-Elevens on lock we only smoking out of
King Palms baby you already know what it
is and if you go to
kingpoms.com
kingpom.com kingpom.com
and you use the promo code bootleg Kev
you will save 50 off at checkout half
off at checkout fifty percent off if you
go to kingpom.com and use that promo
code the promo code is down below go run
it up try some of these flavors too man
the peach pineapple the Strawberry
Shortcake they just got so much going on
there's also all kind of dope smoking
accessories you can get half off y'all
what are we talking about save 50 off
kingpom.com promo code below it's either
bootleg or bootleg have them these promo
codes got my head hurt try both of them
all right one of them get you 50 off God
damn it anyway let's get back to the
interview how many female fans have your
face or your lyrics or your logo
tattooed on your on their body is it a
lot now oh that's a few it's a lot it's
like north of 100 like 2C or two times
or like yeah north of 100 yeah north of
100 ways north of North I might be close
to a thousand a thousand women running
around here yeah it might be close to a
thousand that because they show up they
show up to the concert I mean I hope so
yeah especially this tattoo the broken
heart oh man do they get any sort of
like hey here's like a you know like a
fan fan pack or something I'm gonna take
a picture with you you'll take a picture
yeah I'm gonna take a picture and I'll
probably sign something for you yeah of
course
I can't imagine how weird it'd be to
like meet a human being who likes like
hey look we have matching tattoos or
this is you this is you and then it's
not me but it is like the tattoo artist
was terrible terrible oh my God
yeah I'd be like is that me uh all right
so uh 21 Savage Khalid future won't be
on the final version on the deluxe but
who is there anybody else on the album
no no that's it I don't really like
features like that yeah you you're not a
big feature guy I don't really got many
friends man you always say that you
don't have like a lot of music industry
fans no look who I pull up with the
listen you're gonna see me here with the
same people every time how like how
often are you saying no to like you
getting on other rappers records you
gotta be in high demand every day yeah
we saying know the features every day
like I just saw uh I spice did a song
with Taylor Swift like if Taylor Swift
calls you saying yes hell yeah you got
to do that yeah it makes sense yeah yeah
it makes sense if it's something that
makes sense if Morgan Wallen Morgan
Wallen you could get Morgan Wallen bro
if I can't get Morgan well then I will
get them all you got to do is say
first of all ask them not saying that
and if he says no I'm not saying that
I'm not doing that what are you watching
on TV right now Tuesday are you
streaming anything are you binge
watching anything with your lady nah not
lately I want to go see The Little
Mermaid oh the movie yeah I haven't seen
it yes that is I I think that's I think
that's some real [__] [__] yeah gotta
go see a little mermaid they spend 150
000 on her hair for the movie they said
no way yeah 150 000 yep how the [__] did
you do you spend 150 000 you know what
I'm not even gonna ask that now you
gotta watch it a woman a woman to figure
out how for sure did you watch the new
Fast and Furious movie no I want to
watch that too and I wanna watch John
Wick John Wick is [__] I haven't had
no time to do [__] John Wick's the one
that's one no that's the that's the best
one have you watched the the first three
yeah part four yeah part four somehow
shits on the other thing any anything
with with guns I'm watching anything
with guns yeah I love action movies bro
yeah no I think John Wick might be the
best action franchise ever yeah
did you watch snowfall
no there's guns in there so not anything
it hurts are are it was a snowfall was a
little too like not modern for me it's
from the 80s bro yeah I can't now
what about Yellowstone oh [__] about the
80s you watch Yellowstone Yellowstone
Now Kevin Costner it's about Cowboys and
[__] no that shit's fire bruh fire fire
I'm missing oh you gotta tap in movie
it's a TV show with Kevin cost see
that's the problem I don't do good with
TV shows you watch movies I watch movies
when are you gonna start acting [__]
probably like next year next year is
time next year it's time yeah I'm yeah
I'm [__] every every [__] show
movie Everything how has the transition
been from the diamond teeth to the
normal teeth I'm still learning how to
talk less maintenance yes yeah cause you
got to get them [__] took off and then
you got to get your shits like it's a
lot because you actually for people who
don't know your previous teeth were like
permanents yeah so like it's like no
joke it wasn't like you're popping a
grill in and out nah this [__] was stuck
every day you got a floss you gotta like
brush and then you gotta brush every
like two to three times a day like [__]
too much man now you got the pearly
whites pearly whites they see my teeth
they'd be like you have such a beautiful
smile yeah baby if 45 000. oh you're 45.
well yours look actually great you know
a lot of times uh
a lot of times when people get the teeth
things can look a little uh you know
I'll pay 40.
yeah yeah [__] people should look big
right I feel like like hey hey you share
your your label made the baby's got some
[__] teeth bruh yeah he got yeah he
got wait he's got them teeth you know
what I mean him and A.D you know 80 from
no jumper my brother A.D baby she's not
big no baby got them things on them bro
like he looks like I go [__] up some
corn on the cob bruh oh my god I've
never seen her [__] looks like but you
know what though I haven't seen baby yet
when the last time I seen baby
I'm gonna bring baby up here man I'm
sure he'll come up here soon he's got a
[__] hot record yeah no he love baby
he's a great guy I love it we're gonna
come over here together we got some
teeth though we're both gonna smile for
the camera your teeth look like they
just look like regular they look regular
see I won't lie that's what I wanted
though I honestly bro I feel like I'm I
got the best teeth out of anybody Tif I
ever seen listen I'm not analyzing too
many teeths out there but I would say
you might be right
look at these shoes they look great like
this is nice team forty five thousand
dollars well spent hell yeah what the
[__] this is beforehand I had a little
Gap and see my sister was like that [__]
no hell no uh Lindsay I'm dropping next
or this Friday right next Friday it's
this week yeah arms out will this be out
okay this will be out we'll we'll we'll
put this out Friday tomorrow okay is
today Thursday no we'll put it out
Friday so it's out right now go
streaming go stream the album Deluxe
coming soon yes Yes tour uh tour starts
really yeah tour starts well two months
two months almost two months it's
already sold out if you ain't got
tickets go [__] yourself yeah go [__]
yourself no way no don't go [__]
yourself listen hey see when I'm with
this guy I'm bad influence if y'all come
up here be ourselves the questions that
he's gonna ask you be prepared for them
this is for all the artists out there
that's trying to come up yeah be
prepared for the questions and be
prepared for this interview there it is
this guy's an [__] Tuesday my guy
boom hey appreciate y'all watching
another interview brought to you by our
good Folks at hard now listen y'all when
you're in Las Vegas you get in that
[__] Uber you land at the airport hit
that taxi tell them to take you to
hardine the number one premium cannabis
dispensary in the [__] world y'all
I'm telling you you walk in they treat
you like a king or a queen or whatever
you're into all right they got the
craziest selection to premium cannabis
you'll see period anyway let alone in
Las Vegas but just anywhere all right
not only can you go get the best tree
you will get the best experience the
best customer service the best bud
tenders you walk in the hard Dean and
that [__] just smells amazing they got
their own [__] scent literally you
get into my car I got a bottle of it my
car smells like Harding because it's
just the best [__] place
um go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to their
website
hardinglasvegas.com all right when you
go you're in Vegas you pull up tell them
I sent you they're gonna take care of
you the right way all right look they
got these things in there man these Moon
Rock uh pre-rolls that I just had that
just absolutely melted my face off
shout out to Heart Dean all right you
gotta go [__] with hard Dean man Harding
underscore Las Vegas uh thank you all
man I love these guys they're like
family to us and uh hey we're gonna drop
another interview soon if you're
watching this you're at the end of the
interview though much love